Ned Brockman Ned Brockman an absolute
Legend of a man running a whopping 3 800
kilometers from Perth to Sydney day one
in pouring rain strong headwinds blaring
sun and pain no normal human should cope
with
and I've never been in so much pain I'm
just like wriggling like in terms of
like the Run pain and I'm just like my
eyes are on the back of my head I'm
going this is what am I doing like I am
in the middle of freaking South
Australia and the doctor goes look mate
it is going to [__] kill you to run
but it was never like I'm gonna quit
Ned Brockman reached his goal of raising
a million dollars he raised more than
that to combat homelessness the 23 year
old Sparky receiving a rock star
reception as he ran the final steps to
Bondi Beach
[Music]